to welcome
[Music]
everybody to the most wholesome and
light and breezy show on the Internet
today the HD podcast we come here to
feel whole and happy and our hearts are
warmed and everything feels good in the
world even though it's not excuse me his
chug allotted hubzero today's episode is
sponsored by ring you know them you love
them
today we have a very special guest you
know him as Big Ed from 90-day fiance
specifically before the 90 days we
featured him in a previous episode he
put mayonnaise in his hair to moisturize
and in preparation
yeah sure moisturizes dry scalp in
preparation for his young beautiful
bride from the Philippines who is gonna
be seeing edy
joins us today and not only he's add
such a wonderful great character he is
going to show us how to moisturize your
hair and scalp using mayonnaise with of
course who else but young beautiful Zac
the sound lad is volunteering his body
and soul and head to big Edie to
moisturize that is going to be happening
after the first break you were not gonna
want to miss that is gonna be so much
fun
but until then we do have a lot to talk
about
now I'm gonna give you a fair warning
okay everybody says Ethan don't talk
about politics so noted I forgot I'm not
going to what I bring you today is
political memes there's been so many
great gaffes and goofs on the whole
spectrum I'm going this is not and this
is not what you think it is don't turn
off this is fun times only you're gonna
see what I mean
but I do want to ask before we get
started
Ian you went to that big Bernie Sanders
rally in LA right there was like 30 I
35,000 people there
yeah I did it was it was packed it was
very very busy in there how was the
energy uh very energized you get swept
up in it when there's that many people
in a big room
all passing disease around you know back
and forth in the name of political
change I didn't know you were so engaged
politically well I mean it's whether you
agree or not there's something about
going to these types of things and
hearing these people talk people who may
be the president someday it's right it's
energizing for sure
whatever your feelings yeah it was
wondering though I mean it looked really
cool it's it's good I mean think it's
cool that you're politically engaged
like that I was worried about
coronavirus though I'm not gonna live
with 35,000 people there did you notice
people being safe for people uh minding
were you mindful of the like how do you
even you know I mean how do you keep
safe in an environment like that well
like if someone comes up and goes hey
bud you mind if I spit in your mouth I
don't know yeah they asked me in two
months we'll see but not right now
so very wise so Ian has doing his due
diligence to Purdue militance to protect
himself and all of us from infection so
thank you Ian and the music was good oh
right there you saw a public enemy
without flava flav right yeah awesome I
heard about it all over the news
afterwards
I mean it's so funny at correct me if
I'm wrong I am so Flavor Flav's sent a
cease-and-desist to bernie saying don't
use my music but how could he he did
that without the consent of the rest of
the band who supports Bernie that's
weird right that's why they're firing
him probably and they're like yo I don't
know wasn't is that right in is that
what how they build it as a poor
performance by Public Enemy radio which
apparently is not with flava flav it was
something like that but he said it was
conveying the idea that he would be
there which wasn't the case he later
clarified and said I have nothing
against Bernie don't get me wrong and
also I don't like Trump but I don't want
to endorse anyone so that was his thing
but it's not his group so Chuck D said
no you're done you're fired
Wow
people were joking about how Bernie
broke up public at him after all these
years those two guys so divisive well
unfortunately for Bernie sloppy joe
biden as i like to call him took a took
a big win on Tuesday Bernie's not out
for the count though but what I do want
to talk about as I promised is the memes
now Bloomberg has we've all followed
eight a massive [ __ ] on Tuesday -
everybody's joy and I do think it is
encouraging I will say in a way because
it proves that even with half a billion
dollars spent you cannot buy that
election that's true that's what I
suspected and that's what I think yang
was saying when he was here you know
what so can buy and buy but you know and
you know what I saw some reports about
that really emphasized that is
apparently a lot of because you know he
was just spinning not just on the
advertising but tons of money unlike
hiring people to go canvass for him and
stuff and there's like a bunch of
reports of people that just took the
money and then they go and while they
were canvassing they would just canvass
for somebody else because like hey and
that's the thing is like you can buy it
you can try and buy your way but if
people don't actually support you it's
not good see I'm still better I didn't
get any of that Bloomberg money how do
you spend half a billion dollars and I
hear on like a fairly large show with a
with a young a voting audience right a
voting age I didn't even get like a
milli half-a-million I'm saying like
damn they saw you had Yangon and they
were like this guy's ain't getting to
the core so it's not last time I have
his ass on so anyway memes we're not
talking about politics we're talking let
me so here Bloomberg tweeted out you
guys gonna love this so nothing we got
paid for yeah I don't wanna make it no I
would disclose if I was paid by anyone
yeah so Bloomberg dropped out after a
disappointing show yeah
these memes are so cringy like dude and
Bloomberg years
you're an old crusty old yeah
show this this is a clip from Star Wars
so that's a really good point basically
it's just the part where I'll be yeah
keep it small and scrub through it oh
it's just the scene from Star Wars where
he goes if you strike me down Veda I
would become more powerful than you ever
imagined and then Vader strikes him down
implying of course that because he's
dropped out now he will be he endorsed
Joe Biden and he's gonna be sending
spending a trillion dollars he's a force
ghost now yeah he's a force ghost now
and Joe Biden apparently is Luke
Skywalker but damn he looks like a force
ghost to me so anyway but then Trump I
mean so cringy right oh Jesus and then
Trump responds with another Star Wars
clip I believe our gift
Spaceballs baseball tiny Vader this is
the actual premium or with black
Bloomberg a billionaire then like ninth
the White House I think was in the
Commons I'm sure somebody just
government official in charge of moons
Secretary of Interior gifts that area
means so that was a fun exchange happen
on Twitter now here this is why Bernie
should be President this showed up on
the internet and I have to say it is
pretty compelling you know tell me why
I'm sorry I know what's convinced dude I
make fun of Bernie for being old because
he is like 77 right or 78 for somebody a
is their copyrighted music on this
probably yeah yeah keep a close eye on
the sack you ready yeah
so I wish we could show audio I'm so
sick of the [ __ ] YouTube so a water
bottle gets Occidental II knocked over
by Bernie and his uh excitement and he
catches it like a young spry man like a
good catch while the water is pouring
out and calmly
places it back on the table save some of
the water it's absolutely safe in the
water it was totally gonna spill
everything but ya know that was
impressive for an old man I have to say
man I have to admit I'm impressed you
seen those videos of him playing
baseball and stuff like no no oh really
yeah I mean you still got it yeah I mean
he's 78 you know a little better me but
yeah I mean like it's like a decent
pitch and I mean should I throw it on
I'll see if I can find it but yeah my
point just being is that he's definitely
pretty spry for his age damn like if I
did that now what be like he'll tell me
you saw that
that's 78 um I don't get the whole age
thing to me seems totally fine Neela
have you been I see him I mean I see him
talking seems totally fine okay you know
I guess I'm just an ageist yeah I don't
but you have to admit there's not many
good years left at 78 because he let's
say he's 70 or he's 77 I think so
he's not gonna become president tell
he's 78 he's got four years of his first
and when he finishes first time is gonna
be 82 could be important for years you
know okay Bernie Sanders for president
you heard her here look I voted for the
guy people accused me of class warfare
let me just remind everybody I donated a
thousand dollars to his campaign I
publicly endorsed him on Twitter and
Here I am
I voted for Bernie Sanders and by the
way I'm talking about it we didn't even
talk about what did I do I'm just saying
I'm celebrating the his reflexes he's
like [ __ ] neo
matrix you're not under attack
I'm always under attack so shout out to
Bernie he's looking good
now speaking of coronavirus here's Mike
Bloomberg you know coronavirus aside I
mean this is just
and by the way Mike Bloomberg posted
this on his own social media with the
caption when in doubt rip the crusts off
look at this he looks old it's
disgusting I hope you post this so he
goes in for a pizza he rips the crust
off he shoves it in his mouth this is on
his Instagram that remind you I think he
licks every finger every single one five
fingers in the mouth so weird
yeah regardless of the virus I would
never do that
no and that looks like a communal food
right cuz there's like a big bucket of
coffee that's communal food Mike what is
wrong with you my god why would you post
on your own social media and he like
really deep throats the fingers too
right like they go like it's like out of
the cartoon right like if I if I'm at
home and maybe I got like Cheetos or
something like just the tip maybe if
your hands are clean but he deep throats
his fingers I gotta watch this again man
I mean how do you live this long doing
that he's like 78 too and fine I feel
like if I did that I would have perished
when I was 60 you know so Mike Bloomberg
is out and deservedly so after watching
that also this was a great clip that was
making the rounds on the internet man
this is so crazy I think everyone was in
pure shock by this clip on MSNBC what's
this guy's name the reporter Dan he's a
really Williams yeah he's super famous
reputable guy I mean I know he's famous
for getting fired from NBC Nightly News
for lying about being attacked by but
he's a newsman I mean yeah he used to be
the the main anchor on NBC I mean he
used to have a good reputation
he's a newsman yeah he should know
better than this yeah well anyway what
was the story he went to Iraq and he
said they were getting there being fired
at yeah
people like to you know pretend like
they were in serious danger when they
weren't hmm
yeah you shouldn't pretend that there's
actually people getting shot at we
should we should not trivialize that
experience right I just found it what
you just Ryan Williams apologized for
lying about his Iraq helicopter crash
yeah like crash yeah he made up some
whole like story about they were getting
shot by an RPG or something it was like
really why would you make up such an
elaborate lie it's gonna be easy to
prove yeah I mean he he fessed up to
lying about it and then he got fired but
they eventually brought him back but his
shows in like the middle of the night
yeah there's it like midnight 11:00 an
hour or yeah at 11:00 that's right it
airs at 11:00
the 11th hour exactly so you know he's
he's not exactly the I want to show the
I want to show called the the 15th hour
it's on at 4:00 a.m. yeah okay so here
it is guys this woman is speaking about
just how much money Bloomberg wasted on
the campaign now listen closely um
somebody tweeted recently that actually
with the money he spent you could have
given ever Romaric 'n a million dollar
got it let's put it up a screen it when
I read it tonight on social media it
kind of all became clear Bloomberg spent
five hundred million on ads u.s.
population 327 million don't tell us if
you're ahead of us on the math he could
have given each American while them
million dollars and I've had lunch money
left over
it's an incredible way of putting it
disturbing it does it does suggest you
know what we're talking about your time
is editorial board must have had so many
opportunities to figure out that it's
wrong right they graphic yeah they
planned this conversation so obviously
there if he spent five hundred million
on
and he could have given each person
about a dollar 30 not a million dollar
who did if he gave each person a million
dollars what do we say it was like
quadrillion I think I think it's not
quite quite I think it's like 327
trillion I think it was more than a
trillion
it was around cuz if you do if you need
an astronomical amount of money I mean
it would be 327 million times a million
it would be examine right it would be
like all the wealth the world has ever
known time span no it's a dollar thirty
thirty fifty oh it's a dollar fifty that
doesn't make sense it's not dollar fifty
read are you sure I owe a dollar fifty
to some rich because I did five hundred
divided by three to seven genius a
dollar fifty two well and I just it is
it's three hundred and twenty seven
trillion is what he would need for 27
trillion yeah yeah that's more than
every country's GDP combined I think so
there you go there here's two apparently
educated smart people I mean what is
wrong with you I love how they it feels
I'll just take it for granted
look how smug they are they're like
someone really put in context for me
it's disturbing I gotta say when I read
it tonight on social media it kind of
all became clear bloomberg spent 500
million on ads u.s. population 327
million don't tell us if you're ahead of
us on the math he comma head bro stop
aboard
oh I'm ahead man oh my god dude this is
like simple arithmetic a million a
million is the same quantity you don't
have a burden to convert all right given
each American 1 million dollars and I've
had lunch money left over
it's an incredible way that it could I
feel like a million dollar check would
be a life-changing for most people yet
he wasted on ads and still lost yeah
except he could give you a dollar 50
that life-changing
freedom then yeah
that's alva freedom today not damn but
the truth is that um she doubled down is
that right uh yeah I think yeah I think
I think she heard she doubled down and
said I don't have the the tweet but what
she said was okay I know that my figure
was wrong but the point the larger point
is that he could give every American a
million dollars if he wanted to which is
also vastly untrue because if you go
he's worth what is he worth like fifty
five billion right something like that
yeah so if you go fifty five billion
divided by 360 million just roughly 327
okay
thank you let's be precise here math is
important 327 million then what do we
get if we take all of Mike Bloomberg
money and we divide it equally among
every American resident you would have a
hundred and sixty-eight dollars per
person
cool life-changing so as far as you know
far from a million I'm just saying I
mean there's a lot of people that live
here 327 million is a lot there's a lot
of people god damn so there you have it
lots of good times over on social media
this week then Joe Biden the
front-runner
I mean Joe's just a meme factory listen
let's be optimistic about Joe if he does
win even if he gets the nomination were
guaranteed so many great gaffes but if
he becomes present I mean all bets are
off in terms of the gaffe production the
calf reduction is gonna be theory I
gotta say I'm not a Joe Biden supporter
but if he were to get the nomination the
Trump Biden debates
I'm not gonna say I'm looking forward to
that but that's gonna be and next and oh
my god man I I it's gonna be insane they
think is that Trump definitely has more
mental he's not declined in the way they
just crazy but yeah I mean he's sharp
he's pretty sharp so we like especially
that aspect of his personality of like
getting in digs at people and just them
just generally being a dick he's really
realized he's great at so it's gonna be
a hell of a show exactly gonna be a hell
of a show
yeah well anyway Trump vs. Bernie P I
see I would it's less funny it would be
less entertaining because I think Bernie
stays on point right yeah he does he
wouldn't I don't think he would be
easily provoked and he just he always
stays on message Bernie the 1% other two
percent yeah if you take a look at
percent or the one thing everyone
started making fun you think he's not
you kind of start with a percent of the
two percent if you take two no do not
percent feel like I would enjoy it more
because he's more he would become more
about us I agree real debate yeah well
Joe Biden's gonna challenge him to a
push-up contest yeah I know he would
thinking of Joe verse-by-verse Trump
kind of like it's gonna give me anxiety
why does everything honestly and I hate
to mark on the same thing it's like I
wish everyone was in so freakin old like
even Trump how old is Trump he's like 77
the same age - yeah I mean all three of
these geriatrics Pro it's like it's like
weekend at the bocce court or what is
that there that again the other old
Aussie ball yeah it's like it's like
weekend at the bocce ball court [ __ ] I
want someone weather whose brain is in
their prime being the president in some
cultures you look up to that yeah
they're wise their experience but the
birthday of old brains
they're alive yes there was there's
positives and negatives about you know
well do me
generally who's the CEO of companies
these are not 75 year olds or 70 80 year
olds are they maybe they are probably
get them out of them are yeah what do I
know well it's what we got so you work
with what you got it would be nice
though I shut up Ethan let's watch more
jobs go buy it in so we're talking about
Joe Biden gaffes first here he is this
one made the rounds him confusing his
sister with his wife which is not
exactly the best look bunt a you guys
decide
[Music]
[Music]
you know this one didn't bother me I
mean it's funny but I don't think he
actually thought they were yeah each
other
I think they switched on him that's what
he said text Joe 303 300 still loved 303
300 they making you do text United 2 303
300 is doing that nobody's gonna do that
boomer none of these taken on their own
I mean it's not like you know he's
accidentally called somebody the n-word
or something you know none of them are
like well he did call that one got fat
yeah that was awesome
Ford yeah well here but but it's it's
about the pattern you know what do you
do it's free it's a GAF compilation yeah
exactly
well here I mean on after watching this
next clip I'm definitely voting Joe
because he makes a hell of a promise
here let me now that's a hell of a can
do is text united keep trauma secured
cancer Alzheimer's and diabetes I mean a
lot of people do that a lot of you said
Trump couldn't deliver on the on the
fence on the wall this is one that I'm
gonna hold his feet to air on one more
time
text boomer to 303 3
[Applause]
Trustin he'll definitely working on a
cure for Alzheimer did you consult with
anyone before promising cures to cancer
[Music]
you got a vote Joe come on you guys you
gotta get this guy in office and then
Tom Steyer who's out obviously another
goon I know we argued about this last
time damn but he did spend like two
hundred million didn't he he's gone a
lot I mean he spent 200 million we could
have all got like 2 million no what a
day I could have got like 2 cents
he got even less than Bloomberg this guy
spent 200 million bucks and people still
like just barely barely even know his
name you know what I mean well anyway
this was his epic get hit this was his
epic rally I guess I don't know he's
getting people excited
oh there's probably copyrighted music so
let's mute it we have a muted thank you
but here he is raising the roof with
who's this group on stage Ian is this a
famous artist look at these old people
he's doing back that ass up Wow I even
know he was I mean look at this can you
believe it looks like a Bar Mitzvah and
he's had a little too much wine
oh nice let's go steyr hey wait you
can't play this
this is free are you kidding yeah well
it sounded like a real drop 8 star your
star you're back that ass up back that
assets tire steyr spreads his butt
cheeks spread those butt cheeks
thanks for the million never see you
again hey must be nice to be a
billionaire you could have given each
American a billion dollars he shredding
cut loose I mean he's definitely my room
for just going for it yeah you boning
fire you gonna write him in mmm look at
him he's so embarrassed right now though
you could tell so that's tired he's gone
it's really dumped appreciate that
Barney has had no goofs I haven't seen
any oh I mean I'm sure I'm sure yes this
is what I was saying about Joe it's like
everybody gasps against people too much
wait hold the phone
eel is right I don't think I don't think
bernisa never spoke out of turn
or slipped up he's the badass I haven't
seen any hairy leg comments from Bernie
okay I guarantee you it's out there fine
say that is a supporter of him fine
month
I mean he's tried to find a Bernie goof
Oh try it I will try and I've loved kids
sitting on my lap I'll play dumb oh yeah
that was the best when he called this
Joe Biden called someone eight dog-faced
pony soldier God with the sound Lions
dog sounds good and while Dan looks for
that I have a bonus clip of Oprah eating
[ __ ] on stage she's not a presidential
can life she was so kind of this place
bonus for there
definition of what wellness means to me
this is my definition not yours just an
idea because you're going to be defining
it for yourself wellness to me means all
things in balance
just talking about them while talking
about balance you got a little oh I did
oh I am young
I think that's copy it's copyright free
but let's meet it just I do want to
watch her eat [ __ ] multiple times yeah
she's the Beth that's crazy that she was
talking about balance I know it's like
so good it's almost like a sign from God
he's like God would like flicked her
over got him
who is she endorsed doors to anyone I
think she would endorse Biden no if I
had to guess probably the amount of
money she's got damn what the amount of
money she's got you give every American
two million dollars so that's that
that's all you I'm googling for Bernie
gaff and he's gasless I mean there's one
there's an article from September of
last year and it's like a real it's
literally titled a real gaff from Bernie
Sanders and then the gaff it's like
nothing funny at all it's like he
misspoke about some policy issue with
Mexico exact like nod doesn't count it's
not like a bite in style gaff I mean I'm
sure it's still out there but yeah
obviously he's he's a lot more with it
than uh-oh
slightly yeah see I don't I feel like
Trump needs he cause of sleepy Joe he
doesn't strike me as sleep he's really
just sloppy I feel like my nickname is
better and when you think of slot is
great I can't believe more people thank
you I feel like it is really good and it
reminded just something gross that
everybody hates like look how disgusting
that is like to invoke that image when
referring to the Joe Biden sloppy joe
biden and he is sloppy yeah exactly he's
not sleepy yeah I don't really get
sleepy vibe from him you know you won't
taik about it
sloppy joe I was looking at it like
that's that's a meal
I've always even as a child hate sloppy
joe same has been the most asked and I
like ground be if I like hammer it's
just disgusting its putrid I've always
hated that yeah yeah my family my mom
used to make it not like super often but
it's just wrong rotation and I just
always hated slope you know why they
call it a sloppy joe because there's no
business being between bonds cuz it's
like you know it doesn't even make sense
of course it's sloppy how is that a dish
good question you know all right well
it's break time we have a quick
commercial break and then we are going
to be joined by Big Ed who's gonna be
putting mayonnaise and Zacks hair we're
gonna be having a ton of fun I promise
this gonna be the episode of the not the
decade is ten years the century is 100
years episode of the century I thought
you're gonna say millennium millennium
maybe it might be of the millennium
thousand years okay so we'd be right
back guys don't go anywhere right now is
the perfect time to keep a closer eye on
the things around the house with ring
products a lot hop happens just outside
your front door but how can you keep
things secure when you're not at home or
when you are at home that's when I love
ring the most because I want to know
what's going on around the house when
I'm there and that's why I can sleep
peacefully at night because with the
ring I get the motion detectors and I
know what's going on and now you can see
who's there anytime anywhere thanks to
ring and their home security products
ring is on a mission to make
neighborhoods safer each of their
products is designed to keep you your
family and your belongings safe and
secure or from video doorbells and
security cameras to smart security
lights and alarm systems with ring you
can keep an eye on things from wherever
you are in the world now the product
that I love with ring I got the doorbell
and I have four ring floodlights all
around the house
so if anybody approaches the house I get
the motion detector on my phone it gets
beamed up to the cloud so I can always
recall that and God forbid your power
goes out or the inner
goes out it's on your phone beamed up to
the cloud
baby it's amazing the the floodlight is
actually my favorite product because you
got the floodlight if someone approached
you've got the video you can zap them
even with an alarm on the app you [ __ ]
you hit him with that alarm dude and you
could talk to him - but like hey dude I
can see it what's up that's probably the
best alarm just like a BA Hey Dude
what's up where you going
it's affordable it's a custom
it's the perfect security to keep you
guys safe the video doorbell lets you
answer the door check in on your home
anytime for any we're full home security
systems gives you everything you need to
protect your family pets and property
without there were security cameras you
could check in on every part of your
house so you'll never miss a moment ring
helps you stay connected to your home
anywhere in the world it detects motion
from people come on your property
receive notifications on your phone
tablet or PC see hear and speak to
visitors in real time from anywhere it's
the peace of mind of knowing that
everybody your loved ones are safe get a
special offer on the ring welcome kit
when you go to ring comm /h 3 the
welcome kit includes the ring video
doorbell - and the chime pro that's all
you need to start building custom
security for your home - this so go to
ring comm /h 3 that's ring comm /h 3
welcome back I am joined here today with
the one and only legendary Big Ed from
90-day fiance
your hair is looking moist and and very
healthy
now what is your hair regimen well I dye
my hair for the reason for the
mayonnaise is about once a month I have
to dye my hair I'm which drives my
daughter crazy but because I had managed
to the dye everything yeah the guy the
color of dye she's like ad you know it's
so via obvious but most people can't
tell anyways it irritates my scalp
because I have sensitive skin so my
co-workers he's really kind of my best
friend's raccoon brand he's like you
know putting mayonnaise in your hair or
she is why
told me to do it so I tried it and it
worked and I've been doing it for about
about nine months now
Wow and it really makes a difference but
you do smell like an egg salad sandwich
so you got to make sure that you you
rinse it out thoroughly one time I
didn't and somebody's like what smells
like yeah yeah and that was that church
I'm kidding
so let me ask you this did you try other
products before you turn to mayonnaise
um for example moisturizer yeah no I
mean I I get a keratin treatment like
about every probably six months but it's
like a hundred bucks so it's kind of
expensive
that's the dye yet no it's a it's
keratin is a natural I guess it's a it's
a it's what your hair consists of so
it's like a vitamin I see so it's a
treatment the heat they heat heat it in
but mayonnaise is 239 a bottle you know
so and do you get name-brand mayonnaise
or do you good the do you find that a
different label of mayonnaise matters
you just get the cheapest one I get just
whatever like craft is like you know for
afters yeah and it's usually at my eye
level too so I'm right but yeah it Kraft
is is go with Kraft go with craft every
time I do use the same mayonnaise on
your hairs on sandwiches well send your
bottles no that's a very good question I
like mayonnaise on my BLTs but I don't
really use it in my house anymore other
than for my pair did putting it in your
hair spoil your appetite for mayonnaise
someone yes I'm like I don't like I
don't like mayonnaise on anything other
than a BLT mmm I love mayonnaise you
like mayonnaise I do not as much as you
apparently well ed is from 90-day fiance
we want we've become familiar with Big
Ed on on this clip here or he put
mayonnaise in his hair to moisturize it
I've been instructed to say the
following Ed Big Ed here we go make sure
to watch 90 day fiancé before the 90
days airs Sunday nights on TLC aka they
say not The Learning Channel in bold
ok so we have to make some make that
clear
oh really so say that again they they're
not the learning
oh they're not yeah they they have they
have a disavowed learning okay got it
yeah they're just DLC although we're
educating people about mayonnaise
mmm-hmm I'm kidding that's true
so at bigoted tell me I in the preview
you have found a beautiful young bride
from what was the country on the
Philippines the Philippines and how is
that going is the show is the show shot
live or is it already has it already
happened this is first time this is your
beautiful fiance
yeah that's Rosemarie Rosemarie yeah so
there are 13 episodes and I believe that
includes the tell-all
so all filming has been completed okay
yeah so are you allowed to say what's
the status with your beautiful Rosemarie
no you can't say this edit
you met Danielle you will me see okay
because Wow yeah but I like oh but you
are going into the so you're shooting
before the 90 days you're going to be a
star in the main show right well I'm I
can't say too much oh I some but you
know they cuz it's you know obviously
but I can tell you this it is one of the
most surrealist things I've ever done in
my life it was unexpected I did not I
didn't even know about the show before
oh really
yeah I basically met her sorry I met her
on Facebook and fell in love with her
obviously and then we were we were
talking like up to four times a day
facetiming for about three months and
she's like when you're coming when
you're coming so I finally bought a
ticket posted that and then I walked
over to my associates desk and she's
like you should do you know 90-day
fiance I'm like what is that and then by
the time I got back to my desk my buddy
rich who's on the show sent me the link
so I filled out that link nice fifty
four-year-old in love with the 23 year
old with a 29 year old daughter and I
bought a ticket and I was on the phone
with them within two hours and the rest
was history they just they're like oh
this is magic oh yeah just like what you
said the other day like yeah they yeah
they they're like he's in I can't wait
to watch your season as a fanatic of
90-day fiance I have to admit that I
think the last season was a little
a cluster that's not to say that I don't
love the show so when I saw this clip I
was like there's hope yet yeah and that
man is in the hair yeah and that really
meant a lot to you because I've I've
been getting a lot of like like body
shame and a ton that's not right yeah
that's not at all but so to to know that
you guys your reaction they may be on
the show it made my day
like I'm like wow well we're really
waiting for the season to start joke
it's gonna be our favorite show and you
know we dug in we found the content
you're such a character you got a you're
you're having so much fun you are a ball
of joyous energy and we love to see it
now how does she feel about your
mayonnaise does she know about your
mayonnaise well she probably got it now
because they use your point oh she
didn't know about well you did recorded
so thank you probably yeah yeah she
probably saw that but um no she didn't
comment on it no no no yes she never
yeah but eventually if you guys do get
married she's gonna have to either apply
the mayonnaise or at least partaking in
some way yeah if you look at her hair
though oh my god that's one thing I love
about Rose her hair is like amazing and
you know she she's from a Mike like
almost a third fourth world you know
country it's really tough there no
indoor plumbing you know no yeah it's
really tough how is it when you're
visited it was it it was you know did
you [ __ ] in home I might have to squat
tell me about cuz I've never [ __ ] in a
hole I did in China when I was there
years ago similar similar to that you
put you just kind of squat and do yeah
yeah I don't know that I could poop
squatting to be frank with you well
actually no kidding that positions
actually better blue I this is what I
heard right it's actually better with
your knees bent
what was it sorta I didn't get the good
news is I didn't get sick you know I was
so worried about getting sick I didn't
you know you just you have to be super
aware but um you know the conditions
ever country you know it's tough but I
mean some of the most beautiful women in
the world
you know come from such a you know a
poor challenging country and they're
super nice everybody there was treating
me really well and it was it's still
kind of like unbelievable in a way like
I don't really did I really do this
thing that her family was were they very
skeptical of like I always wonder in
these shows when I walk out it's like
the the white American comes in and
scoops up the beautiful you know is
there some kind of stigma did you found
among her family and friends and
community in general right well so as as
they're releasing as they're releasing
clips of the show like TLC go they
they'll do they'll release the following
weeks episode parts of it and I saw some
of that interview
I don't you're probably aware but two
weeks before I was to leave her sister
was shaking me down like oh yeah that's
a I've seen that happen before
yeah I know you know and and leave me up
into this point that's that's all I ever
heard like for example my ex-wife and my
daughter Tiffany they were huge fans of
the show right so immediately they're
like what are you doing right because
you know you work in a profession you
have to be very careful you know they
can make you look you know really good
or bad and right um but you know I
didn't do it for the show I was you know
I'm in love I did it for it was real and
everything you see about me it's me I'm
just a natural goof you know that is the
thing I wonder when they do these
reality shows us how much is embellished
and how much of it is is genuine yeah so
I can tell you this they told me one
time don't look at the camera don't look
at the camera and don't act just be
yourself and bowed and literally I mean
they told me that once and I just and it
got to the point where I just forgot I'm
just
cameras were even there like I'm feel
like right now it's this is so natural
but yeah so so so mom and daughter were
a big fan of the show and they warned me
you know that it's a shakedown she wants
a green card and you know you know that
it's true and you know Moe
people not all people but most people
from you know desolate areas they think
every American is a millionaire mm-hmm
they really believe that and when they
when TLC did the release tells he go did
the release last week they show her
sister going you know she body shaming
me - thank you very much she's like yeah
well he's big he's bigger than Rose but
you know he's rich you know and which is
not true I'm not rich right I'm funny
you know I'm generous sure you know but
but I'm not rich well we certainly
cannot wait to see to see what happens I
know you have a twitch channel I'm gonna
help you plug what what our plan is that
I want big Edie to give us a manís
tutorial young Zak is in a kimono he's
got a glass of wine much like yourself
and what I would like for you to do is
put on those gloves and start massaging
mayonnaise in his head to give us a
tutorial of how are we going to
lubricate our domes I love it but so so
before that you're your twitch streamer
is that right I'm yes so funny story one
of my best friends he's actually the
he's just a really good friend
he he's with raccoon brand and he thinks
I'm funny as heck we went to Japan in
April and I would just be like
personally told me don't bring a bunch
of luggage because we're on in a Norfolk
trains all day long what did I do
I brought big pieces of luggage in fact
he was the inspiration raccoon brand was
the inspiration behind this sticker he's
like you you're gonna be a meme people
love you because I just do dumb
naturally I do dumb things like you saw
in the video with you know vacuuming the
cookies and there's a thousand different
ones anyway so he just thinks I'm funny
and I'm when it comes to computers I'm
like I'm just not very smart in a
different generation so he's like you
should become a streamer and so he
helped me set up you know this is Big Ed
and and help me set up my twitch channel
I have a buddy on the East Coast
his name is Boozer and mud mud light
there with pix Berg studios so they're
the ones that actually do my filming
they see something in me that I don't
see so they're like okay we're gonna
make you a streamer and people are gonna
love you and so we're playing a game
called sea of thieves and
that they're like okay you know you're
you know you know you're not smart so go
to the hole and in shovel out this ship
you know so it doesn't you know you
basically see if thieves as this game
where you play with about eight people
around the world stream you live and and
on their online camera they're on camera
we can see each other or we have little
characters on the boat so naturally they
like adds old you know put them
downstairs and you they got you in the
and the in the undertow what do you call
it the bow the undertow yeah yes
leveling a call yeah yeah just doing
like like mundane no sir
well I'm a huge Malbec fan as many
people know so in streaming is fun I'm
not very good at it but I have all the
microphones and the headsets and I don't
know how to hook up stuff so they have
to stop Midway and explain to add hit
here's how you turn on your microphone
you know your mics too loud or turn your
music down or you're in your boxers you
can't be in your boxers when you're
streaming which oh no oh really yeah I
didn't know that that's a lot probably I
still on Twitter sure they don't allow
shirtless yeah well big big Edie I see
you've got the face on the shirt on the
cup you've got it everywhere
got the stickers let's go ahead and and
so this is Big Ed right yeah yeah you're
you're available wherever you are
available yeah if you go on twitch.tv
forward slash right not a back slash
yeah not not a back slash yeah not
thankfully that's absolutely
wait hopefully I think it's I think it
is yeah this is big Edie I'm pretty sure
that's it I mean see what I mean yes you
can find me interest if you google at
this is big ad you'll find me
okay so twitch calm awesome so okay
we're ready to do this let's continue
this interview and our barbershop over
here on am I ready okay hello so big ad
if you'll you'll join us right here
it's on it's actually uncanny the Zen
loves right there so you know it's h3
one it's actually one well you go ahead
and show it as AK if you would please
the the boys were kind enough to honor
me with with the h3 wine so thank you
very much
now II D go ahead so your your the gear
you know what you're doing so I'll leave
it to you now ed well since I've got
here and you're prepping have you been
to any coronavirus hotspots in the last
30 days no yeah no heck no yeah good
because young Zach here is very worried
about the corona virus frightened and he
was just a little bit nervous about
somebody touching his head today but
just for the record you have not been to
Italy Iran China or anything like that
no sir
and how long ago in the Philippines
because there is some corona but what
then oh I'm too close oh my Atika tis
too good I know Philippines I believe
there's some corona virus there is that
right no but um yeah but when I was
there I don't think it was it it didn't
exist yet Zak are you feeling okay sorry
they're more worried about what people
are posting online about the corona
virus then which is becoming a bigger
deal than what it actually is people a
lot so just be careful wash your hands
wash your hands that's big Ed's advice
yes wash your hands you have any other
advice on how to keep safe from the
corona virus
yes a mayonnaise in the hair there's an
arrow oh thank god the perfect antidote
so here we better with what we go for it
yeah I'll just process okay so this is
best foods which I'm a crafts man but
it's okay okay so how you feeling I'm
good oh good the question number one if
I get mayonnaise in the road are you
gonna freak out no okay good okay
perfect okay all right so um here we go
so it's this simple now so Big Ed is now
taking the top off the best foods we've
got the spatula and so the technique
here
so this spatulas a little bigger than
then what fits in here but that's okay
specialists too big it doesn't fit in
the top so Eddie is no no Edie Britt
over here no bring it over here so we
can see on camera it's right here that's
good
absolutely so Big Ed is dumping this
mayonnaise on the spatula my god we are
and so we what we have here is a nice
ring of mayonnaise on the spatula that
is looking beautiful Zach would you like
to smell it before we engage no okay so
don't worry about making a mess it's
totally fine oh and so what you're gonna
notice I'm Zach is it's gonna be cold so
cold what it's cold okay and the second
thing you're gonna notice is it smells
like Zach go ahead and tell me from your
experience how is this going that's not
that bad tell you the truth so let me
ask you this it's very cooling how old
are you I'm 22 22 gee oh you're a kid oh
my god so you don't die you don't no no
no but but we all oh so so so big ad has
reached into the mayonnaise jar and
grabbed a handful of mayonnaise
is this comparable to the amount of
Managed you would use on your own hair
well Zach's here is actually a little
longer than mine but um yeah this is
about the same you want to make sure
that you you work it in oh my god I'm
gonna get this out that's a lot of
mayonnaise I have to say but them but we
have to moisturize now how long do you
recommend keeping the manis in the hair
to get maximum good question half an
hour oh now do you find them but you'll
find out dude that after a while you
don't even you don't notice the smell
because you're all of the hair follicles
in your nose they shut down oh you you
acclimate like when you take an stinky
dump and you're on the toilet for thirty
minutes they stop so what I'm basically
doing hopefully he's not getting too
excited I'm working the mayonnaise into
the scalp that's important you get a
close-up the end of the amount of
mayonnaise that's running through Ed's
fingers here because there's quite a bit
of mayonnaise in the do you need more
mayonnaise may I recommend one more here
no how you feeling all the smell is
getting
okay it's supposed to okay so that you
know yeah you missed the sideburns these
that needs yeah just to be thorough okay
here we go alright so now what I have
here is his tail because what you're
gonna I'm gonna pull so I'm gonna take
his tail and we're kind of I'm actually
gonna wrap it into the top of his head
and because it's mayonnaise it kind of
just sticks it's a natural am adhesive I
got a haircut and so wrap the tail back
into his scalp
the smell is starting to get to me
well you will yeah there was a shower
cap yeah oh so a hair clip I don't think
it's gonna be necessary so what about
paper towels you guys got a paper towel
the spatula bigger okay
that's important that you measure the
size of your spatula because it doesn't
always fit into the the jar it's not a
big deal I'm not upset or anything okay
Zach turn to me so now I'm gonna clean
some of the mayonnaise off of your skin
no we don't want the manage to be on the
skin only in the hair is that right that
is correct only because of the odor
okay so Zach I'm only because of that
odor he said okay okay okay I asked you
a question do you ever take a taste of
the man's not at this point okay just
you know I know you I just met you but
no I'm kidding
nobody we we're kind of talking about
that earlier that Oh can you breathe
okay sorry
so um so what I'm basically doing and
this does a couple things turn this way
so Big Ed has put a bag over Zach's head
at the moment so what this what this
does basically is it it Oh does it as
you killed the owner Zach no don't worry
about that Zach bigad has spilled a big
dollop of mayonnaise behind you but not
to worry I don't mind
that's for later at this one you need to
take another sip of wine take a sip of
wine okay and how are you feeling relax
okay does anybody have a timer
yep okay whoa um let's go 15 minutes 15
15 minutes is that enough that's enough
ask you a question what was my question
I was gonna ask you a question I forgot
anyways all right I'm not important
so let's leave in 5000 I question was
how are you getting this out of your
head yeah that's what I want to do well
we have running water and a sink I'm
sure we'll figure it out or you were
welcome to leave it for more now if not
like bleach if you leave manis in the
hair your hair falls out is there a
similar effect have you left managing
your hair for too long I'm not sure
that's a very good question
what's the longer no the you know I fell
asleep one time drinking Malbec and I
think it was in there for an hour and a
half really didn't notice you know in
effect what's gonna eventually happen is
the whiteness of the mayonnaise it's
gonna go away it's almost gonna be like
an oil right so that's when your that's
when you really know you should so when
the whiteness goes it's time to wash
right correct the important thing though
too is that are you doing is that you
have to you have to wash your hair twice
if you don't get it out of your hair and
you show up for work you know the next
day a your pillow is gonna smell like
mayonnaise see everybody at work what
wants to know what smells like egg salad
sandwich well I thank Zach for for Thank
You Zach for for putting your your head
in the game we're gonna give this 15
minutes I'm gonna need to go back and
take care of the audio obviously okay so
and then whoa and then if you have time
we'll go ahead and go back in I don't
know the ED is on a tight schedule I'm
gonna go back into the studio here one
moment
well Zach's the best I called my golden
boy cuz he's pretty much down for
anything now I have to say that Big Ed
we've had a list celebrities in here
I've had I've had who are famous people
we've had five minutes yeah I heard I've
had Jack Black I've had I loved had bill
burr I've had Andrew yang I've had a you
name it I have never had a guess with
such a tight handler as you
yeah yeah she's uh she's pretty good
though Danielle I love her well there's
a publicist from from TLC the unlearning
channel and she has made absolute sure
that we are on time we have 30 minutes
max with you the certain topics are not
discussed and I just have to say that I
think Barack Obama probably has a looser
lid on top of the menu though you're a
hot commodity you're worth a lot of
money to them thank you and I you and
and you know and I could see why your
gem shadow much I'm so glad we made this
happen I have we have three other
interviews after this that's why we're
on such a tight schedule they wouldn't
let me put manis in your hair I know and
I knew you wanted the minute I saw your
podcasts I'm like oh my god anyway I
already knew what you wanted to do and
you keep it tight to my chest I'm like I
know what you thinking truthfully I did
I wanted in Zach's hair and so I'm very
happy with the outcome of this Zach how
are you feeling we have a Wiccan switch
to zap nice pretty good let's sit down
and have a look at you yeah
is that is the smell dissipating at all
no not at all okay I hope it does I'm
just kidding it will I promise
yeah we're currently they did that I'm
about once a month so I dye my hair and
usually I wait about a day and a half
you know two days and then I'll do the
mayonnaise treatment mm-hmm well so when
can we when can we watch you but begin
so you'll be able to see me well they're
they're runny repeats like every almost
every night which is kind of cool but
the next episode which is episode three
airs Sunday 8:00 Pacific Standard Time
Sunday on the TLC 90-day fiance before
the 90 days airs Sunday night if you're
not watching big Edie
fall in love with this beautiful young
Filipino girl and all the drama that
will unfold getting shuckin down by her
sister the manis in the hair everything
I mean it's got it all
am i right laughs gasps it's got goofs
yeah it does and if I can add one thing
so I was body shamed in high school you
know they told me no neck head you know
all of that and but the funny part that
was is I used to work out with all the
football players and I actually got
stuck in the in the locker room I got
stuck in the neck machine so it became
kind of a funny things
I've always you got stuck in the neck
machine yeah is the neck machine it's a
machine that you did strengthens your No
so so I was up I was told that I'm never
going the neck machine but so I was
always somewhat of a you know teased you
know throughout my life and and the and
about 11 years ago I was doing in home
sales and I'm at a client's house and
their three-year-old daughter
four-year-old daughter comes in since
next week goes hey can I draw you I'm
like sure absolutely so she proceeds to
draw a box you know and which was my
body and then arms and legs hanging out
and then she'd do another box on top of
my on that box with a smile and she
showed it to me and I just freaking
started laughing but I kind of realized
at that point she wasn't trying to be
mean like she was just she was telling
me this is how she sees me which is not
a bad thing so the point of the story is
when when the show's first came out like
the the promos I got a lot of you know
you know body shaming and making fun of
and it kind of brought me back to my
high school days well most recently I've
gotten letters as far away as South
Africa gentlemen on the East Coast Abe
and they're writing to me saying look
you know you have you know you have you
know balls of steel you know you're so
open to rub many neighs in your hair on
national TV and you know you're willing
to put yourself out there how do you do
it you know I'm this one guy's like you
know I don't want to you know sometimes
it hurts to breathe and people make fun
of me every day so I just want to give a
shout out to Abe and to a Maryland in in
in South Africa that you know don't let
kfs which is a syndrome I have it's a
couple file
don't let that define who you are you
know and be yourself and love yourself
for who you are so yeah so thanks for
letting me say that so now now I'm
loving what's happening to me because
I'm able to really impact people's lives
and the response is now you know you
know pretty good and and I don't really
hold the people that make fun of me I
don't you know it's just I think if they
understood you know how it makes people
feel they wouldn't do it you know so
just you know keep that in mind and
just you know let's you know try to love
each other more well a very heartwarming
kind message from Big Ed one that's well
received here at age your beautiful who
you are we love you here we immediately
fell in love with you the character the
the the joyous person that you are
mayonnaise
ballerina the whole shebang so that's a
true story so we wish you a love I think
we wish you success and she's very
beautiful young girl and I hope that you
have a lifetime of love and happiness
with her thank you so much and thanks
for being my friend thanks for report
you know being a fan of me you know it's
you know now I can you know I can you
know 65 million people or 65 hopefully
sixty five or six yes yes five million
yeah
65 trillion people heard that message
and it is because of you guys well I
hope to have you back in here again yeah
I would love it let's stay in touch okay
I will keep in close touch with your
with the Gestapo in the backstage from
TLC she's really sweet she is she is a
sweetheart she's super nice yeah and you
guys are she did threaten you know when
you're in the bathroom oh she I'm sure
she's a weapon you know wait well thanks
for letting me know
though she had a well yeah it's probably
for me not for your your she's
protecting it so we look forward to
having you again with a quarter watching
you and we wish you all the very best so
they good thank you God heard that
before
what's that hey you guys big up bigger
no okay I like you call me the goat
what's that that's the greatest of all
time greatest they'll go to I love that
you know what it meant
yeah greatest of all time it's an
acronym big heads go with thinking ago
here thank you for your your your this
was fun I had a lot of fun we're gonna
do it in this will probably be my
favorite interview today well thank you
very much I hope so this better be yeah
it is
you're who you going with you use you
can move meet with a bunch of stiffs
like what Fox Fox is one of them that
Entertainment Tonight there were she was
she's a big fan of the show like you
guys that was this morning and then
I have Access Hollywood hmm you know mah
reez Mario is out sick today so I get to
interview somebody else but I guess I
didn't yeah
maybe they'll have me rub mayonnaise in
their hair I really I know I wouldn't I
would not I will not cheat on you yes
please don't please stay loyal to the
okay thank you we are gonna just go I
don't know what we're gonna do because
we have to cut here cuz that's a goodbye
to big edge so we'll figure it out
this is goodbye we are back big Edie has
exited the building what a wonderful
time we had let's throw it to Zak who's
really the one that we all want to know
at this point how long's the man has
been in your hair is that Oh 15 minutes
15 minutes so you've got the full effect
of the moisturizing of the mayo god I
hope so yeah
so tell me how are you feeling the smell
is really starting to get to me and get
to you you're feeling nauseous
completely yes okay and that's
interesting because you are the mail guy
I mean you love mail yeah and the white
disappearing like you said yeah it is
yeah I don't you want to take white at
all can you take the the turban or a cap
I guess it's still in there a little bit
we still have samanage but you just look
greased up so bad we can't smell through
the camera yeah I'm sure that's what
everyone's thinking I wish I could smell
that I feel bad you know Zach wants to
loved mayonnaise and I feel like we've
tortured the poor guy so much advantage
can you silly man enjoy mayonnaise very
lightly very nice yeah well dance right
next to you and he has a mayonnaise
aversion dan how are you doing smell the
shadow Dan the least you could do is
smell the shower cab after when he was
first putting it on you it was that room
was disgusting I saw you dipped out for
a minute yeah but it seems to have
dissipated I don't know maybe the he was
right I mean the shower cap I think it
contained it so you're smelling it but
damn well can you smell the shower cap
for us for those oh no no I can't even
to make the show just a little more
entertaining well I get two seconds just
come on
here right now like give me a break come
on he's turning away from Zakir but even
he won't even face it well fair enough
Zak we thank you for your sacrifice
sacrifice sacrifice and we have
basically a kitchen sink with dish soap
that Zacks gonna attempt a water shampoo
from him oh you did well how do we have
my responsible from one of our sponsors
no man escapes shell I think that's
meant for your pubes but that'd be great
if you separate shampoo for the pubes
all right well go ahead and wash your
hair out Zak thank you so much
and you know big ad what a treat I mean
what a character
I can't wait to enjoy that that season
you know I've never got close to one of
these one of these 90 days I know people
I was so official so it's already all
been filmed so I think what happened is
I didn't get total clarity but is that
there before the 90 exactly that's all
been filmed I don't think she's because
she doesn't even know about his
mayonnaise habit so that means she
hasn't yet come over hears that we have
no audio but we can use our imagination
there's no idea maybe there is is there
audio in I'm not hearing anything okay
so Zach he really has beautiful long
black hair there's a lot of mayonnaise
he's getting a lot of soap and Dan is
back there with the hand can we dad is
there any way to get audio apparently
not that's okay so well we could check
back in with Zach as he continues okay
who washes hair but yeah they get
awesome did really awesome and um
definitely like he said it takes a lot
of courage to go on that show it's true
you've got a like open up and they they
show everything one insight that was
interests
things I never knew how they met these
people as a how does 90 day keep finding
these these unbelievable stories yeah
he wrote in mmm-hmm fascinating and
within two hours I loved that they were
like yeah called mine oh I hear lots of
noise from the bathroom what is going on
back there hold on can you tell Dan to
get the handheld because I want to be
able to hear what's going on there
because it sounds brutal like it looks
like he can't get the mayonnaise out
like it's just sticky or just a
microphone just the microphone so we can
hear Zach I am sitting here waiting dead
air dead air we're trying to figure out
how to get audio in so we can hear from
Zach Eva what is the problem back there
with Zach is that Manny's not coming out
[Music]
he was asking so Zach says the
mayonnaise is still in his hair he says
he says the dish is not doing [ __ ] and
an eel is here to confirm you know the
mayonnaise that's it was like really in
there I mean it's not coming out being
as Manny's is a lot of fat and oil and
so you can imagine taking all of oil or
bacon grease or whatever and just
putting it I mean that is you know what
I mean that's studying easy to get out
yeah I can see why Edie likes it for the
moisturizing properties although I did
notice Edie said he has not tried
moisturizer when I asked him I don't
know if he was kidding or oh yeah oh we
have a mic got that the wireless here
okay so we've got a mic so Zeca how's
this going for you terrible terrible
coming out I need someone to pour water
on just terrible all right I guess I'll
do that for you hold on you could just
show them in just show here I'll get the
mic
No so the fact that he's doing this over
the kitchen sink is just got to make
this also much worse is that right Zack
[Music]
go over there was better because you can
really yeah that's good
now how many how many times have you
washed it out Zack this is working this
is gonna this is gonna be really cold
[Music]
there's a lot I'd like the base of his
neck me right now you so my golden boy
Mayo five yeah you know we're close to
getting is much we're probably going to
be able to recommend more shampoo we
just flipped his hair back in my face
that's right I deserve then getting then
the right here get all the way back
there like good na Zack you are the man
that's the man people ID Dan Dan steppin
steppin what better can you do than put
a shower cap on C stand for then if not
but this Mike is coming to an end here
it looks like the mayonnaise is coming
out of sweet young Zach's hair he if you
have a look over the sink so I think I
think we've come to an end here Zach so
thank you very much Papa bus
thank you and Papa bus to you there's
still a little shampoo in your hair
phone to be honest totally honest you
can see but right here the it on the
other side but it's pretty good I mean
yeah you're gonna want a shower when you
get home anyway I'm assuming well how
does a hair feel does it feel moist okay
let me know all right well thank you
jack and thank you Dan and thank you
everybody this is very exciting
I'm gonna give you this Mike Wow Wow
excellent Zach
what a legend little big ads acqui we
salute you
oh my god it was exciting we're having
exciting times here on the h3 podcast
having like anxiety for Zach I know fine
he's a strong he's a dog this is strong
boy mm-hmm well I'm very excited to find
out if it worked you know because
there's a lot of hubbub when he was
leaning over I got to say his scalp was
looking raw hmm I don't do you think man
well that's not good no that wouldn't be
helpful at all well in the meantime
let's move on we do have other things to
get to today um or not we could just
wrap it up - how long we've been going
down oh because of the disjointed nature
it's hard to say probably about 45
minutes okay well I has we start we
stopped and started we said by the end
like I don't know exactly how long even
so I do have the wiki feed segment that
I'm really excited about should we do
that or say that but also what are you
gonna do before the break oh I have a
bunch of I have out the whole show
planned before the break oh yeah we shut
it out of order here a little bit
because we had to get Big Ed in there on
a very tight schedule they said you have
30 minutes max and then we have to get
out the door and get to Access Hollywood
Ethan you alluded this and in the
interview but I just want to emphasize
for the viewers like Eddie was like the
most high value guest we've ever had on
this show like a smart at least as far
as TLC's publicity Department is
concerned yeah we've never had anything
like that with with the number of
celebrities that come through here
nobody's been that tightly sealed I mean
I'm surprised we got him in here at all
to be frank with ya
yeah well how was she reacting backstage
well I was talking to him
to tell you the truth she was laughing a
lot okay that's good yeah I was worried
that she was gonna be like interrupting
and trying to you know well she she
originally asked if she could sit in the
studio during the interview and I was
like no we don't do that and and
truthfully that there has that has
happened before where someone try to sit
in the studio during the interview and
it's just it's just it's not good it's
not good in the studio is its own world
because it's so distracting when someone
is sitting right there watching you yeah
yeah so I insisted that that she sat
outside but it sounds like she had a
good time so everyone's at all good now
on to we are bringing back a time held
segment that we've abandoned for some
reason I don't know why but we're
bringing it back to date Dan will be
joining us right now to send the nudes
as we like to joke it's a play on the
word news of course so without further
ado I welcome to the stage dan police
officer Dede mega doo doo excited it was
fun to reassemble that I had lost the
original stinger from two years ago or
whatever and had to rebuild it a little
bit so yeah this is the the h3 news
bulletin
welcome we got some pretty juicy stories
I wanted to lead today with what is
really an update and I kind of feel
guilty being the one to present this
because this is um this is really a in
territory more than me but this is
breaking news
you all remember little Uzi vert or
little
little QD squirt his Ian's name already
squirt you remember his whole thing with
the the death cults and his album cover
and everything well the album is finally
out I'm happy to report
it's called eternal a top gay mic you
back checked me on that in you know this
is pronounced a take a take what is it
take what is it take it was a word that
was in the original slogan from the
Heaven's Gate people also he's still
known on heaven
don't mean on Heaven's Gate now this is
the new album cuz that's awesome
which yeah that's as if they actually
actually made it to right and you'll
recall the original plan was he just
wanted to kind of do this rip up this is
this wasn't the original album cover but
it looked a lot like this this was the
Heaven's Gate logo that it kind of
parodied and the surviving members of
the Heaven's Gate cult sued him he tried
to fight it saying it was fair use but
it he ended up backing down yeah
and so instead what he did which was
kind of cool is just a few days ago on
March 2nd I believe he tweeted three
alternative album covers and he let the
fans decide he did a poll and I gotta
say I think the fans did well I think
this is definitely the coolest out of
three yeah yeah now was just the guy who
was tweeting at me to shut my my white
mouth that was little a see was beefing
with me on Twitter yes and it was really
seemed like a misunderstanding if I
remember right we've swapped the beef
and the beef was squash yeah well that's
good to hear yeah have you heard the new
album is it good I listened to some of
it and it seemed cool so far I'm excited
to finish it it only came out this
morning
literally Wells House is breaking now
except breaking news right there so so
congratulations to little cutie squirt
continuing on in entertainment news our
old buddy
Weinstein I don't know if you heard but
he was found guilty on many not all but
many of the charges against him and
immediately upon being found guilty he
said that he was feeling not well and
was taken to the hospital which a lot of
people thought was a bunch of Phooey
but uh he survived and now he is in
Rikers so good riddance
Riker writers arias one that is that's
the one in the middle of New York City
yeah that's kind of infamous so he
remains in New York or at least in New
York tur till the end so congratulations
to the city of New York and the word
or all your stay yeah have fun and
finally in entertainment news I don't
know if you've heard but William Shatner
aka Captain Kirk course is going through
a divorce
Oh No yeah very sad how old and evie
he's way up there he was pretty old to
be doing a divorce yeah like at a
certain age I feel like unless you're
married to a young wife
do you know 88 years old how it is a
wife
his most recent wife because he's been
married many times
his most recent wife is Elizabeth
Shatner and she is I'll tell you right
now she does not look 88 hmm she's 60 so
you know just 28 years what do you make
of that how long were they married since
2000-2001 it looks like they've been
married for just 19 years and she's
gonna leave his ass at 88 years old
their separate ways and so yeah he's
going a separate life eternally probably
pretty soon maybe but you know
thankfully it's not too vicious of a
divorce they're going through divorce
court and everything and Los Angeles
Superior Court just ruled that they I
guess he owns four houses mmm and so
those are being split evenly between the
two of them but bill is getting all the
horse semen [ __ ] will and we gonna read
this headline William Shatner gets horse
semen and divorce settlement so a person
X got Kentucky home that seems like a
bad trade so I guess he's very into
raising racehorses and I don't know if
you know this but race the semen of you
know winning horses is worth a lot of
money you do have an idea how much like
a load of semen goes to to breathe more
racehorses because that you know it's
considered if the horse wins a big race
it's considered like he's got great
genes and so that if you wanna you know
right it's very strange
with humans too you know if you go to a
sperm bank like they your IQ and your
fitness and your height your sperm goes
for a more premium you can get my sperm
on the on the bargain bargain bin yeah
apparently the American Triple Crown
winner American Pharoah Wow
his his sperm no no but I just you are
asking how much it could cost one
insemination from American Pharoah who
again won the Triple Crown biggest prize
in Beijing $200,000 I'd be out there
jerking that horse off all day I wonder
if he just got a bunch of loads bang I
maybe I mean apparently this horse semen
was equivalent to a house right that's
awesome so she got the house he got he
got he got to come there you go I wonder
if he just has like a bunch of calm and
like frozen or something that's what I
imagined yeah room for it you know funny
you got you milk horses are you milk
cows but then he's gonna be kind of
milking yeah you sure it's a very
different kind of mellow fascinating
that turns me on
hey also from Kentucky I yes it might
[Music]
all right moving on from from the world
of Hollywood and into the digital realm
of entertainment here's and if you guys
saw this and you know this is obviously
very relevant to us but Tricia posted a
video she is retiring from you to know
she's warning to her how well she says
that she no longer which this is
actually this lines up with what she was
telling us when she was here last is
that she doesn't really make any money
from her YouTube anymore and it's more
trouble than it's worth and you know
she'll be focusing on her other
endeavors mmm was flirting yeah all
right but but the YouTube is a strong
promotional tool I mean she wouldn't be
a squirter she is without these right
but maybe you know
she's just found that's her oh my god
that is well Trish is gonna be here with
us next week well next Friday and that's
why I decided to bring this up because I
mean I worried at all that she's no
she's a friend of the show yeah she
would never see what it is important to
note that if you want to apply to be
Trish's future husband you better do it
now because the time is I mean this may
well be the deadline yeah in fact our
deadline is Sunday which we're posting
this tomorrow on Saturday so they
watching this on Saturday this is
basically your last shot cast podcast at
h3h3 productions no that's what it was a
podcast at h3h3 productions calm get it
look at that we got the we got the lower
third it'll say predicate on that's a
good question it's too small to know
it's spelled correctly are bullying me I
am NOT bullying you that's the sound
bite
Oh clap those cheeks I am NOT pulling
you you can sound bite that seven I am
NOT bullying you okay yeah beautiful and
then continuing on with this
I am bullying you are you even listening
in so continuing on with the news from
the from the digital space I guess you
could say did you hear about this former
faze clan member who fired a weapon
you can't show it I asked Arielle okay
so we won't show it cuz I was like can I
is now everything's so tight and it's
just so it's so obnoxious I go there's a
clip of the coronavirus meme what was it
oh the the woman from the CDC licking
her fingers as that can I show this he's
like no like that and I say oh can I
show this guy firing the gun he says no
okay well we won't show it but if you
want to check it out for yourselves go
look up
soare Karl clip is all over YouTube and
twitch yeah he was just [ __ ] around
on his stream on Twitch and you know
trying to act tough with a firearm and
it went off shot at handgun loaded
handgun on his desk shot his can of jet
fuel which is hilarious
he was then immediately suspended from
twitch his clan like a sore clan dropped
him but the reason I actually brought it
up more so I mean it's hilarious on its
own but then he had to refute a rumor
which was going around that his fiance
had left him you know he had tweeted I
guess her name is Alicia just so you
guys know at least he and I are still
together I don't know who decided to
start spreading this most supported
thing in my life she's unbelievably
upset for me and still is at least I
still have her where you scroll down and
immediately see that the person
responsible for that rumor was our old
friend keemstar I can't so I would never
report anything that wasn't yeah weird
he lost his girlfriend twitch
partnership and kick from his team all
in one stream dramaalert so cool well
that's that while clearly you're wrong
yeah you're right I think they did break
well he's a serious journalist yeah and
how dare you question is credible
please go after him star when you
inevitably go into a sociopathic rage at
somebody having said something about you
right focus it on dan please announcer
thank you and finally moving on to tech
news your favorite company Apple I'm
sure you have probably heard about this
lawsuit they were nailed on
intentionally slowing down their phones
as the battery were out well they are
going to have to pay up that's not
enough
half Billy yeah so not enough money
right it's so much money right the from
that it looks like that class action
would result in iPhone owners getting
about 25 dollars a piece which when you
consider the fact that people you know
their phones were slowing down so they
went and bought a new iPhone several
time what do you do it what do you
really do with $25 yeah give us the $25
will fix your battery right they get the
money back and the funny thing is
originally when they admitted at Apple
offered a discounted battery replacement
at $29 how ironic right many people
claim they'd already spent hundreds of
dollars to buy the new phones Apple
didn't reveal the cause of the problem
they'd known they could have justified
yeah so it's you know Apple's rationale
for doing this is that as the battery
decays and gets older if they slow down
the processor on the phone the battery
life will last and so you know they're
arguing this was a conscious decision to
improve battery life
would you rather your phone run slow or
last [ __ ] they pre Clent they pre
can that answer 10 years ago
innovation doesn't happen here exactly
well well yeah I mean again at least
they are paying something it's probably
not nearly and what well hopefully it
just doesn't happen anymore
now that it's out in the open I guess
that's true it may incentivize them to
not do it maybe or maybe they'll just
decide hey we made way more than five
million dollars doing it so let's just
keep doing by the way who does that
money go to I always wonder when like
corporations do these super slimy [ __ ]
like who gets this money oh it's a class
action lots of class action oh right so
what that means are the lawyers get a
fair share of that you get to everyone
gets 20 bucks and we get 250 jobs for
years and finally in some science news
apparently
life will not be ending within the next
month there is a massive asteroid that
there was like a little bit of concern
could hit us but we are being reassured
and let me turn that off reassured by
NASA that we're all good this asteroid
that is between 1.1 and 2.5 miles wide
oh my goodness yeah that's a big boy
it's enough to have to wipe out all life
on Earth kind of are they gonna show the
canoe fullscreen this video uh sure
let's have a look here I think this is a
more this is rod doing about this map
all these dots though are all of -
droids that are flying around so there's
a lot of a lot of junk out there Zack
are you more afraid of Corona or these
asteroid belt Corona mm-hmm it's
probably how's your hair feels that yeah
yeah we don't it's up in a ponytail
right now or a man bun can you feel it
though is it like smooth right it
definitely is smooth it's kind of gritty
to tell you the truth no no it's not wet
anymore it's not like can I feel it yeah
sure I think we're gonna have to get the
real portal on Tuesday it's not like
silky smooth you know but it feels fine
I don't feel great you know but I think
you just you you know you're yeah he's
way more familiar than then we will ever
be Wow well thanks for that update
my fingers do smells faintly of
mayonnaise
it's like eucalyptus and mayores so just
to wrap this up we are not gonna die
from this Astro
but reading up about this led me to did
you know they actually track all of the
possible extinction-level events in our
future now the probability of these you
can see is quite low like this one for
example it's uh you know minus 4 on the
scientific scale so that's you know
point what zero zero zero one chance of
hitting us not impossible right but
that's the thing so I mean it's not a
huge list but all of these are giant
asteroids that are gonna fly pretty
close to us within the next hundred
years or so only twenty two entries
that's not bad
yeah I mean that we know of so are be a
lot more outs or most our biggest boy
here is a two nine oh seven five well
let's see actually this would actually
be yeah this is by far the highest
chance this one and it has 62 chances of
hitting the earth I see so what is this
percentage here well so I made a figure
if you click it shows it four point nine
percent like an earth impact that's what
I'm saying that one's pretty good one in
twenty I don't like those not impacting
when it says between 2095 118 so we've
got will be a little bit of time I will
have will have missile a way to you know
we'll bump that [ __ ] out of this was
the movie with Armageddon Armageddon
there well Armageddon actually will send
some blacksmiths some oil derrick guys
and that's right I have no problem no
worries
yeah so um and that that is done news
that's what's in goes well thank you Dan
I think usually what I would want to do
is end it at this point but let me just
make sure that there's nothing else I
wanted to say here at the bottom of the
show last chance for Tricia podcaster
h3h3 productions calm and that's that
so thank you Dan and have a terrific
weekend everybody thank you and
see you next week so you're doing the
wrap-up from there yes we're doing the
wrong it's what I I need help closing
the show this whole episode has been
yeah we were kind of off the wall Stan
we're closing the show on them I think
that's the new thing the news ends and
we go all right all right well we'll see
you next week everybody think thank you
everybody
all right
[Music]